By one breast is being completely eaten away by the cancer, slowly but surely, is that
normal?
Well, it's never normal.
Is it common?
Yes, it's common.
So, as the cancer is continuing to grow, it could be basically kind of devouring the rest
of the breast tissue.
That's actually a better scenario than the two are just getting larger and larger and larger.
So, that's when the cancer is continuing to grow and the breast is getting eaten away,
that's actually a better scenario than the scenario of the breast, the two are getting larger and larger and larger.
So, we've seen plenty of that over the years that is a little scarier and doesn't always have this best outcome.
You see this happen with other women with breast cancer, their breast seems to tissue, seems to just kind of get eaten away and the things stop.
So, you're already doing everything you can.
I know you've recommended you talk to your oncologist again.
It seems like they're not really giving you any solutions at all.
I am a surgery really isn't probably even offered to you at this time.
So, I don't know that I would change anything.
I know this person that we have just talked recently, so I don't think there's anything else to change.